hello folks welcome to rational
science I'm a little over my
cold uh I had a little stuffiness there
lasted 10 12 days fortunately it's gone
anyways we have a great day today we're
going to be talking about
spin whatever that is
um I hope I'm doing fine here with the
uh video and the sound okay let me know
otherwise and so let's get started I'm
going to start again with uh extinction
extinction segment we're close to
extinction here on Earth we are the last
generation of humans on Earth that's
what we say in this channel okay you're
welcome to challenge us okay anyways uh
let's start with this we have all these
wars going on we have Ukraine versus
Russia Israel
Hamas China Taiwan aeran Armenia North
Korea South Korea India Pakistan and I'm
sure there's several more and my only
recommendation to you is don't pick
sides okay what are sides well they're
just mafias okay and you know the uh
people who rule the planet they don't
care about the petty people out there
you know the ones who go out into the
streets and burn tires and break Windows
those are the Fanatics who choose sides
you know these people don't care and uh
you know there you have a scenario
should you choose Bugs Moran over Al
Capone I mean which mafia do you think
is better okay and so that's more or
less what it comes down
to you know I was recently in uh Jordan
Aman and um it was funny oh the prince
got married uh hashimite with a Saudi
you know they're trying to unite the
crown sort of the the wealth you know
the rich marry the wealth the rich marry
the rich the wealthy and uh turns out
that um you see there that there's a
problem here we have a war between
Israel and Hamas right and an invasion
whatever you want to call it and it
turns out that all the Arabs are up in
arms they're all up set right and what
did the leaders do and this gives you a
little focus on on what's really
happening you know all the people out
there they choose sides they say oh this
is Injustice and that should be like
this and that should be like that and
what are the uh what are the uh rulers
the people who Rule Do Well Jordan and a
couple other countries turkey Etc you
know they're so upset and they recall
their ambassadors they say oh this is
there's an outrage we're going to we're
going to recall our
ambassador uh sounds very cosmetic it's
like you know let's let's throw a dog a
bone to the dog there you know uh keep
them happy you know you would think that
under a situation like this where
they're killing people these people
would be a little more adamant and say
we're going to cut all
Commerce with Israel you know and you
have all these Arab Nations cutting all
their Commerce with Israel not one of
them did so they're all recalling their
ambassadors which is very cosmetic which
is nonsense you know because as soon as
this war ends or whatever it's going to
end Someday I'm sure well they're going
to put their ambassadors right back in
but see they didn't cut their uh
economics they didn't touch their
economics uh because it hurts them as
well they'd be shooting themselves in
foot so they only give Li service to
this whole thing and uh then they try to
figure it out you know in Clos quarters
how they're going to solve these things
so my suggestion is don't take sides
that's what I learned from politics
don't get involved with
politics okay uh there's one site uh
there was a uh an article and he talked
about the end of
humanity Humanity will wipe itself out
right and uh sci-fi put this article
that was published and it's got the this
notion that the 14 most likely ways that
we will disappear right and the problem
with this whole thing with this whole uh
approach is they looked at all the
relations you know between uh technology
and uh you know uh different things that
we have out there and they put them all
together and they say well these are the
14 things that we think may cause the
extinction of man
and as always they have hoped that maybe
we can fix these things as long as we're
aware right that uh what the problems
are and maybe there's a way to correct
them even though they start by saying
that um all species eventually become
extinct it's like you know yeah but
since we're smart we're intelligent we
have technology we can foresee the
future maybe just maybe we can avoid it
somehow or postpone it you know who
knows another thousand years or whatever
ever and so uh they missed a boat these
people are saying
essentially uh that there are all these
causes but they missed the the main one
which is the collapse of the global
economy you know that is a guaranteed
way of killing man you know right now we
wouldn't be able to
survive if uh if we didn't have Commerce
if we didn't have trade if we didn't
have money and just imagine if God waved
his magic w wand you know oh here got
one magic wand right God waving his
magic wand and suddenly makes money
disappear and by that I mean that people
no longer believe in money they don't
accept money you know and so uh you
can't give them money you got to give
them something a little more solid you
know than money and this is the issue
the issue is uh if we can make money
disappear even by Magic right uh what
would happen to humanity well I can
guarantee that we would all die because
without trade today right Humanity
cannot last we need money we need trade
we need Commerce okay H we need to trade
stuff exchange that doesn't happen well
uh we do not receive Food and just about
nobody produces his own food everybody
goes to the store and waits for someone
to put something on the shelves you know
it appears apparently by Magic because
you just go to the store with money
right with bills or with a credit card
or debit card
whatever and uh they give you
food are people stupid they're saying
hey you know I'm giving you something
real something you can use like food and
you're giving you what a number in a
bank account what the hell is that well
the only reason they accept that is
because they can do something with that
number you know they can pass it on and
buy a car or
whatever uh but imagine if people
suddenly realize that that's just a
number you gave them yeah you're on an
island and one guy's got a banana and
the other guy's got a
number let me give you a number for your
banana you know I don't think it would
work you know so money can only subsist
in C under certain conditions and I
think that's what's going to happen
money will disappear because the global
economy cannot grow forever at some
point there's going to be a crash it's
not going to be a simple recession or
depression it's going to be Extinction
that's what it's going to
be without economics we're all
dead anyways here one fell says you said
that Calhoun you know referring to um
John Calhoun who did the experiments
with first with rats then with mice that
was the first to create homosexuality in
the lab yeah one other the first I think
there's couple other experiments out
there uh one with fish that I know of
you know so you got to look around but
essentially Calhoun created
homosexuality and you could say autism
as well in the lab okay or in other
words homosexuality induced by human
intervention I disagree as prisons have
been around since way before Calhoun
right and prisons induce homosexual
behavior and we know for certain why
this is oh
okay so are we certain that the en
enclosed conditions and lack of
available mates of the opposite sex
didn't contribute to these
conclusions
uhuh well what can I tell you first I
want to address that prisons induced
homosexual behavior and we know why that
is well I don't know where he got that
uh I've been through at least seven
prisons my three years uh in The Slammer
and uh no problem I found all kinds of
uh people in there and essentially it's
a microcosm of the people out in the
Free World right there's there's very
little difference and I think you could
safely divide people inside the prison
in two halves you know
General that's just a rule of thumb okay
and that is that half the people hate
them and desp wi homosexuals and the
other have tolerate them and say well
that's their business I don't care you
know so that's more or less the attitude
that's in prison now I just want you to
think about something you go in prison
and H you find this gang right and the
leader of the gang says I think I'm
going to have sex with the next guy
comes in
here what do you think is uh gang
members you know the his Bros what do
you think they would think about him you
would say oh you want to have sex with
man that's what they would think so uh
no this uh thing that they rape you the
first day that you come into prison you
know it um it's a a myth okay it doesn't
happen sex is not that great in prison
and uh so what happens is that you know
the authorities they want that myth to
spread they want you to believe it so
that you're a nice guy and don't go to
prison okay that's more or less it's a
deterrent right
but uh no uh I don't know where he got
this thing that uh prisons create
homosexuals homosexual guy is born that
way and you know I don't I don't know
why anyone would say anything different
if you see a down patient you know Down
syndrome patient everybody looks at him
and says well he was born that way you
know they didn't make him in school or
at home like that you know teaching him
to be like that he was born that way but
when we get to these other things like
homosexuality people or Autism they say
well you know that was
schooling why would you change that
what's different you know and that's
what you got to show you got to explain
what is different between you know uh
being um homosexual and and being a down
pacent is there a difference isn't this
a
mental
disorder well the Psychiatry and uh
psychology associations of America they
said in 1973 and the other one I think
was 76 they ruled that it wasn't a
mental disorder and they took it out of
the books out of the mental disorder
books but why why did they have to do
that because there were so many people
coming into their office say cure me Doc
I got a problem yeah I'm homosexual oh
you're homosexual yeah and so please
cure me what was the doctor going to do
what psychologist or psychiatrist to do
give him a shot in the arm and say okay
you're cured now you know there was no
cure for this and there were so many
they flooded the psychiatrist offices
and they finally just said hey this is
very easy we're just going to say this
is not a problem if you can live with it
you're okay and if you can't well I
don't know maybe you commit suicide or
go to some kind
of care you know association takes care
of you guys you know so that's the way
they handle it so now you got to show
you know why this is so why you know the
the question is why do we have so many
homosexuals today is it that suddenly
they came out of the closet because
there's more freedom there's more
information or was there a real problem
you know where they invaded the
psychiatrist offices and they said in
the psychiatrist said hey you know there
there's a flood here we got to do
something about this and very easy they
said it's not a disorder that's how they
Sol it okay and so today we don't
have these as mental disorders as they
used to
be okay another fellow talking about
similar subject says about C why did the
mice stop breeding okay I think it was
because the mice got stressed out okay
they didn't become autistic they just
moved away from all the fighting okay
you can really mess animals up by
raising them wrong interactions with
their environment cause physical changes
in the brain but you got to tell me the
mechanism all you made is a statement
said you know environment causes these
mental changes okay person now thinks in
a different way uh what's the mechanism
how did the environment change his brain
that's what you got to kind of explain
if you can do that I mean it's I'm not
saying it's something you're going to
think about in two seconds and come up
with an answer you really got to get
down to this because you're saying that
the environment somehow induces changes
in Behavior okay so we got to figure out
how that is so you know density in in
this case right so what I can tell you
is lack of genetic diversity is nature
okay that means we born that way if
there is lack of genetic diversity in
the entire human race as I've argued in
the past uh where you know I argued that
we have a troop of uh chimp
and they have more genetic diversity
maybe 100 monkeys there you know they
have more genetic diversity than the
entire human race 8 billion
people you know you got to explain that
why is that so and the question is again
science is about explaining you got to
explain the the cause okay what caused
that to happen and uh then you have
environment and that's nurture you know
it's uh schooling it's how you were
raised at home uh influence from society
whatever okay so we would call that
nature versus nurture nurture okay mice
and rats did in fact become Autistic or
as uh Calhoun said he said they sto
being mice for the mouse you know the
mice group so they stopped being mice
what he meant by that is these mice were
kind of like you know dumb they were
just in one corner all they would do
come out maybe eat then go back right
they would Chase by some of the other
mice who' bite their tails and made them
bleed and so on but these were stupid
mice they're not the M the mice that you
find out there in the fields or you the
railroad tracks uh that move around
they're smart and you know they're
worried about their environment who
might attack them who they can who they
can attack you know Etc um these mice
were just complacent and in a sense you
can see why if uh these mice did not
have to struggle for food or water they
they were given all the food and water
they wanted they had all the nesting
material Etc they had no Predators so
you develop different kind of kind of M
Mouse but the issue here is whether this
uh Mouse right is um is made through
nature or nurture because all these mice
we're talking about the last Generations
where there was high density that part
is uh uh nurture but they all come from
the same grandparents you know you have
the this founders effect and so uh the
question is did that cause the mice to
be different okay was it was it genetics
in other words going inside their body
and how much of each you could also
discuss that so um you got to look at
the whole picture not only say oh it was
the food they ate or or the density
density obviously was Factor but what
about the the genetics the fact that
they all descend from the same
grandparents and so yeah again was it
nature nurture or both that's what you
got to kind of uh resolve okay and you
should keep all the factors in mind not
jump to conclusions okay just go in
there and say okay what could have
caused all this
okay okay so uh here we have um more on
autis ISM KFL says you should explain
autistic psychology before telling us
what causes it autism and retardation
aren't the same thing they are both side
effects of mutational load okay and uh
well what can I say I'll put this up
here and that is that science you know
we deal with rational
explanations in and we separate physics
from philosophy the two the only two
branches of science you either do
physics or you do philosophy physics
deals with objects causes and mechanisms
philosopy deals primarily with Concepts
reasons and purposes you want to know
why someone did something why someone
behaved in a given way and so when these
people bring up these subjects uh you
know um here we only do physic we we do
not do philosophy philosophy you know we
don't explain reasons and
purposes uh at least that's up what this
channel is dedicated to sometimes we
touch upon the subject but that's not
our main course our main course by far
is physics we want to see how the
physical world works okay and so yeah
when it comes to autism you got that
situation where you say how much of it
is nature how much is nurture nature
would be physics nurture would be you
know philosophy and so uh you know again
we got to start at Square One
uh is autism uh um a consequence of both
okay or is it
primarily you know that we have it in
our blood because we are the last human
on earth uh humans on Earth we've been
in breeding for 200 300,000 years since
Adam and Eve came in you know into the
uh record you know so we've been in
breeding for a long long time and we're
8 billion people now we all come from
those same descend
uh predecessors right so the question is
you know does this inbreeding produce
effects in the long run and that's the
question uh before you that's the one
you got to answer that's the way I look
at at least okay here's another file
says when one
researches um autism rates by country it
appears that every study has conflicting
results no research groups uh can agree
on the data so is it reliable well uh we
don't want to throw the baby away with
the washwater okay uh yeah uh we've been
collecting data for autism for a
relatively short time maybe a few
decades and before that nobody cared
that much about that subject it's a
subject that has grown in importance and
I think in part partly because we have
more more children coming out with
autism and attention disorders and who
knows what else and the question is is
this again a consequence of density is
it the education at home or is this
something we carry in the blood is this
related to uh the fact that we've been
inbreeding for so long in that we've
washed out our genes our genetic
diversity okay so again it it all comes
back to that question you and not easy
to answer I'm say this is something that
you're going to wake up morning say I
got the answer but uh you got to do a
lot of research and on both ends of it
you know not only on the density and
education on the nurture part you got to
look at nature as well you know how much
of this comes uh inevitably in our
species because we've been in breeding
it does it happen to all species and I
say it does it does uh you find a lot of
the stuff among Lions sheep you know
homosexual you'll find it among sheep
and lions and I'm saying this is
something new partly because we have
much fewer Lions today so they have they
can can't avoid
inbreeding at an extreme level that's
one issue but the other one that uh
strikes in my mind is you know we used
to have Lions especially when they
brought them into the Roman circuses you
know uh the
Coliseum and so they they used to know a
lot about lions or they've seen lions
and nobody I can't say all the way from
the Romans but at least maybe a few
hundred years ago nobody ever mentioned
that lions were having sex with lions
you know I mean male with male and this
appears to be something new and I would
explain you know partly not because of
density but because of lack of mates you
know we had about
150,000 Lions in in the world primarily
in Africa what was it in uh maybe 40 50
years ago now there's only 35 30 or
35,000 so the population has been
dwindling and that means that now you
have almost no choice but to have uh sex
with a cousin okay so I think that's
part of the
problem okay another fellow talking
about autism uh says autistic brains are
about 3% larger however for whatever and
this doesn't really translate to higher
IQ okay the uh problem here is this IQ
issue you know um the
IQs uh really have a lot to do with you
know how much you study because you're
going to be doing some math you're going
to be doing some of these uh things that
you learned not that you were born with
so it's not testing your uh you know
your um innate uh intelligence it's kind
of testing what you've learned learned
in some cases and so the question really
comes a little earli is what is
intelligence you know and there I show
the plant cell versus the animal cell
and I'm saying that any cell is the or
the cell itself is a synonym of um of
intelligence because it's
compartmentalized okay it's already it
has a CPU has a center that governs all
its parts and and I think that's the
best way to define intelligence along
those lines and if that's so even plants
have intelligence you know but the
question is people usually think of
intelligence and as something that's
unique to humans uh you know we have
intelligence nobody else does uh animals
don't have intelligence neither have
plants and so the question is what do
you mean by that uh you saying the lion
does not have intelligence I mean he's
got a certain type of intelligence that
he needs to do do his daily work you
know he's got to hunt he's got to figure
out how he's going to catch that uh
animal that he's going to be eating so I
guess he's he's got some kind of
intelligence okay he has a sense of
timing okay he's got a sense of time he
doesn't carry a a watch wrist watch but
he knows if he knows how fast he is and
how fast that animal runs and so he more
or less calculates you know intuitively
says I can catch that guy and that's why
he runs otherwise he he doesn't take the
trouble because it's too far away or too
fast for him and so what is intelligence
you know you have to Define it first and
it's very hard to Define intelligence
believe me that's why I like to Define
it at the root I'm saying that if it's
just a CPU you know a something that
governs you know certain parts of
itself uh I think that's the RM ment
definition of
intelligence okay subject here different
fell says I'm not saying that chickens
are dinosaurs but that there are still
dinosaur traits okay okay uh so the
question you know a lot of people say
well dinosaurs are still
around they're what they're still around
I didn't know that better watch out you
know when I walk into those alleys you
know and what do they mean by that they
mean um they mean that uh you know the
uh
birds
are descendants they think of them as
descendants or as cousins or who knows
what goes through their mind they think
that birds and dinosaurs are more less
the same thing and here you have one
article at least that vouches for that
says are birds really dinosaurs is it
disputed it says there's no longer
really any doubt that birds are a type
of dinosaur ahuh these days the debate
is about details the strong evidence
doesn't just come from fossilized bones
and similarities found across the
skeleton uh but from fossilized soft
tissue okay goes on and it says Birds
belong to the theropod group of
dinosaurs that included T-Rex uhuh so
they're therapod right therapods are all
bipedal and some of them share more
birdlike features than others and they
go with archaeopteris discovered 1961
they go L Raptor and uh there's a couple
more okay and so the question is are
bird you know they put these um these U
uh claims out there and people start
saying oh the the dinosaurs are still
around because they're flying
now and so the question is are these
dinosaurs are birds dinosaurs okay and
that that's the question so you can say
some people say well the dinosaurs never
became extinct because they're still
around you know they're flying around
now you know all these te rexes these
theropods they're playing around okay so
here we have some of the early birds
okay you got there 160 million years ago
that was uh towards the end of the
Jurassic and then you got uh some 125
million years ago maybe beginning of
Cretaceous and you had these
birds did these evolve into uh the you
could call these the dino Birds here the
repto
birds reptiles flying rep now some of
these apparently had feathers as well
and so the question is you know are all
these dinosaurs you know birds and
anything that flies are they uh
dinosaurs and I think we have to
distinguish uh you know certain types of
man animals out there you know uh what
if I told you that you're a synapsid you
know synapses were uh around at the
beginning of the peran all the way to
the end of the peran and then they were
gone forever and so are we mamalik
reptiles as the synapses are also
called and so here's here's uh the
question for those people who say uh
that birds are dinosaurs I'm going to
say that then we're also synapsed for
that matter right because you know here
here you know does does your mother like
look like any of these you know is is
that are these the ones that are in your
family you know these animals the Dem
metrons the uh parasaurs you know they
disappeared you know sometime during the
peran the
uh dimetrodons disappeared first
parasaurs towards the end of the peran
when the Triassic started and so the
question is are we going to say that we
are uh synapsid simply because we share
some commonality with them you know uh
those you know those tiger-like animals
or lionlike animals
they laid
eggs have you ever seen a tiger lay a
egg have you seen a wolf lay egg or a
bear lay an
egg and so yeah we have some features in
common with with the uh synapsis that
doesn't mean we are synapsis and to say
that birds are dinosaurs because they
share some features with them or had a
common ancestors doesn't mean that they
are dinosaur dinosaurs is a different
order than Birds okay so uh it's wrong
to say that birds are dinosaurs first of
all and it's uh you know all these
paleontologists they they they want to
be in the news and they want to say
these uh you know exorbitant statements
make these tremendous statements saying
oh yeah the birds are dinosaurs and
people say oh ah they did a study and
they showed that they're the same now
that's just to create the oo and O and
get their name in the books uh what what
you need to look at is you know that
they had a common ancestor that doesn't
mean birds are dinosaurs and neither are
we you know
synapses okay and so you know you got to
look at these things not jump to
conclusions or or you know synthesize so
swiftly okay reach these gen general
concepts these General uh uh verdicts or
whatever
conclusions okay so here we have PA says
life after death is a CL classic oxymore
life and death affects all animal forms
including parasites and bacteria and all
planets in the universe trillions of
years ago and in the trillions of years
to come yeah if there was life after
death by definition all parasites small
animals dinosaurs and bacteria would
also have to exist sitting at God's
side I think that says it all but
Believers would not be amused yeah life
after death is an oxymoron because what
you're saying is the person didn't die
you're saying the person now has a
different form but he's still moving
around you know moving his arms legs
he's talking he's listening you know uh
so how dead is he does that is that the
definition of dead when when it moves
like the ghost there you know so yeah
there is no such thing as life after
death now the person says well because
then what you're really saying is the
person never died he just transformed
you know from uh a bodly you know piece
of meat uh into a ghost bed sheet I
guess I mean I don't know what a ghost
is what a spirit is the soul you know
concept thinking goes to heaven you know
what is that is there is there a matrix
up there in the uh sky and you form part
of the Matrix and your soul just lives
forever I mean you have to Define these
things if you're going to talk sensibly
and you know know there's no way you can
uh there no such monster is life after
death simply because like this fell says
it's an oxymoron you know life is life
and if you died you can't say you're
alive you're still alive because then
you never
died okay we have a weird world today a
crazy world here we have this uh girl
right and she's a uh she's made by AI
that's what it's called uh what a aana
aana or aana right Lopez right an agency
created an AI model who earns up to
$111,000 a month because it was tired of
influencers who have egos so they
created this image and it's I guess you
can say Photoshop that's the best way to
explain it right and yeah we we get this
world where these uh lots of people
follow these things and they say oh uh
I'm going to look at these AIS that they
created you know and they create them
with Photoshop and they send their money
in because you they're maybe affiliated
with with something out there and or or
just the hits or whatever and so these
people are making money with images and
here are these guys at home and they're
just watching these things and saying oh
look how beautiful that that AI is that
robot that image is you know it's not a
real image it's a one uh
manufactured so we do have crazy world
believe me okay final issue of fell
says says does money exist if it's not
an
object when money is no more humans
become extinct okay does money exist
right now in our present Society does
trade exist if money does not exist and
I answered this follow the other day uh
but he came back with the same thing I
guess he didn't understand so I don't
know if I can you know rub it in one
more time exist object PL location right
you need an object to talk about
existence otherwise you cannot in
physics in rational science in the only
science that there is really you know in
ordinary speech you can say whatever you
want you can say love exists you cannot
say love exists in science okay because
science requires that exist have an
object there has to be a thing there in
order to talk about existence you cannot
say that mass exists or that energy
exists or that field exists or that
charge exists or that a wave exists okay
no such monsters all these are Concepts
okay mathematical concept especially you
know so um exist you need an object and
so again he goes money and trade but
money is a static concept concept right
forget about static or dynamic both of
these money and trade are Concepts so in
science in science in physics in physics
right you cannot say that a concept
exists any concept doesn't matter which
one okay and so I I don't know how to
get through to this guy you need an
object you need a thing you need a table
you need a chair you need a ball you
need a you know the Earth you need a
human then you can talk about existence
so if God wants to exist he needs to
choose whether he's an object or a
concept right if he's a concept then he
doesn't exist so you got an ox and
moreon there but the only way God can EX
EX in science is if God is a thing so
with that has shape that which has shape
so then God you can say exists you know
at least uh if he's got location but
only under those conditions otherwise
you cannot say God exists because if
you're going to say God is intelligence
God is love God doesn't exist by
definition in science in physics under
the definition we have in science if
you're going to go with a definition the
nonsense definition that they have in
order speech which is a ndef no one has
ever defined the word exists then yeah
you can say anything exist you can say
love exists God exists whatever Spirits
exist everything exists Soul exists you
know not in science in science got to be
a physical object so you can't say
conscious exists not in science okay and
so in physics it's irrational to say
that a concept exists okay uh when you
suggest that money uh or trade exists
you are using ordinary
speech okay ordinary speech is outside
the bounds of physics outside the bounds
of Science in science we Define our
terms so that we can use them
consistently and we can make ourselves
understood by someone who's listening an
intelligent person who's listening you
know uh so yeah you can't you can't use
this term exist for Concepts and when
you say money or trade you know you can
say that gold exists you can say the
paper the bill right uh that exists
right you cannot say that money exist
because money is here not out there and
money money is not a thing uh unless you
make it into a thing and and confuse it
and say the dollar bill is money no the
bill is one thing money is the value you
give the dollar bill okay so money is
the concept bill the bill is is a thing
the bill might exist if it has location
money never exists because money is uh
something you give value to and you're
willing to Exchange Trade okay so let's
keep those let's keep the concepts
separate uh from the
objects okay okay so let's move on to
our main segment of today which is spin
okay and the question is what is
Spin and the other day we left off with
this gentleman his name is uh Richard
Fineman and they asked him what is spin
he could not tell us he had no idea what
spin is he was a Nobel Prize I think
1965 when he got his Nobel Prize for QED
and Quantum electrodynamics and he
invented this SpaceTime diagram and all
this nonsense that they have in quantum
mechanics but he could not tell us what
this feature which has been around at
least since the 1920
if not earlier called spin they were
thinking that electrons spin especially
at the electron right and so they were
thinking it was like a top okay they
said okay top spins and electron spins
okay so that was the original thought
and the word stuck they said okay spin
right turns out that they eventually
discovered that spin is not spin okay
that spin is not like you know what you
have with a little top
right and so uh then what is spin
because they could have changed the name
if they found out it was something
different if it was I don't know torque
you would call it okay we were wrong
it's not spin it's torque for example
right or uh jumping up and down or
whatever they said instead the electron
doesn't spin it jumps up and down okay
great but so what is spin if it's not
spin you know like a top what is it and
of course uh since uh good old Fineman
you know he was in the 60s uh you can
say well we've evolved since then that
was 60 years ago okay so let's see what
spin is today we have this gentleman his
name is m o da okay and he asked the
question what is spin okay and so how
does he answer it in general terms well
he says we've established that Quantum
spin is very weird man that's a very bad
way to start a presentation because uh
when when he says it's weird he he's not
being truthful he's saying they're
ignorant they have no clue that's what
he's saying but he say it's very weird
that's not the right way to put it okay
you got to say you're ignorant and you
don't know what spin is that's the
correct way of saying not weird okay
because if it's just strange you would
say well you know it's not uh uh the
spinning of a top it's like jumping up
and down or torquing or something else
that's not what he's saying he's saying
we don't know okay says electrons have
spin but aren't really rotating no one
understands Quantum spin right so don't
tell me it's weird tell me that you
don't know okay uh weird means that you
know in in the language of mathematics
when they say oh it's there's a paradox
it's weird means that that they don't
know squat that's what they mean that's
what they're telling you in your face
and then you have people who listen with
half an ear and they say oh they they
really know because otherwise computers
wouldn't work
yeah tell me about it okay computers
wouldn't work but Quantum says that a
particle can be at two places at once is
that why computers work is that what
computers prove that a particle can be
in two places at once that's the
explanation they give when you put them
against the wall and say but that's
nonsense how can a particle be at two
places at once well we don't understand
and we don't care about that because
that's philosophy or philosophy of
physics philosophy of science what we do
is math we do equation okay so why did
you even attempt to give me a physical
interpretation right if later on you're
going to tell me Well we don't
understand it and we don't care about
that anyway it's not in our job
description we don't do those kinds of
things that's philosophers on the other
side of Campus so why did you try to
give me philosophy right philosophy of
science philosophy of physics why did
you even attempt to give me a physical
interpretation if you're going to give
me a nonsensical one and then say well
we don't care about that
anyways you know you said stick to math
if you're going to do math do math don't
jump the fence into physics that's the
issue okay uh so what does he say well
here uh Mr odad says uh this is spin you
know and there you can see what he's
doing he's really spinning that cube
right um he's suggesting that there's
this field that is being torqued all
around you know the uh the cube there
but the cube tube is spinning I want you
to focus on that he says spin is not
spin but he is illustrating this as spin
you can see the ball there is spinning
okay and so he's saying well what it
does it's it kind of torques the field
around it okay great we don't know what
those lines are those uh um ropes those
uh you know cables whatever those things
are right these strings okay but um he
says that they uh I guess they come all
the way to the electron and so the
electron is spinning and twist these
things around and so what are those
lines I mean I don't see him in the
standard model what are those lines that
he just put in there by hand he put them
in there you know he didn't he doesn't
explain what they are he doesn't tell
you like oh by the way you know those
lines there uh they're this you know
they're strings or they're you know what
are they he just puts them in by hand
saying they're attached to this thing
that's rotating spinning right rotating
around its axis and if it's rotating
around its ax yeah it is spin so he's
saying we don't know what spin is but
I'm going to illustrate it as you know
like a topwood spin right I'm he
illustrates it like this you know he
illustrates it like that but then he
says that ain't so and don't take uh
what I just showed you literally but
then
he does spin it he spins the cube he
spins the ball right and um and so you
say well what does your atom look like
does it have all these little strings
attached to it or whatever no this is
his atom he he shows the atom okay and
it's the standard model that you'll see
out there the planetary model that's
what they always show and they show a
ball in the center which is supposed to
be the positive proton and the electron
you know somewhere around the proton and
the white line there going around that's
uh put in there because it suggests to
you that the electron is going to go you
know in that's the orbit of the electron
and they call that line an orbital you
know orbital or you can call an energy
level whatever they want to call it but
they always put that in there to suggest
that the the electron always goes around
or somewhere around around the proton
okay so this is this is the official
atom and when you say well is that the
atom the quantum atom that's when they
say well no it's not uh you're not
supposed to take it literally we don't
know what an atom looks like they say
okay but they always illustrate it as a
planetary
model you know we've inherited that from
good old um uh Neils Bor and uh what is
it uh Rutherford erns Ruther for
okay we have another Guru his name is
Derek Müller and he's uh confirming what
uh this other fellow mow said he shows
electricity here and what is he showing
he's showing a positive proton right and
the negative electrons moving from
proton to proton from atom to atom so he
thinks of electrons as little beads that
flow and he calls that electricity in
fact he says a copper wire consists of
positive metal ions swimming in a sea of
free negative electrons if there were a
current in the wire the electrons would
just be what drifting in One Direction
so he's saying that electricity is what
you see there the flow of electrons many
of them from atom to atom and so this
assumes okay this assumes a planetary
atom so the planetary atom is confirmed
it is the official atom of quantum which
is subsequently denied okay they deny
this atom first they show it to you they
say this is how what what an atom looks
like a little bead going around uh this
is what electricity looks like the flow
of electron beads from atom to atom and
then at the end of the sh they say by
the way all we talked about today forget
it none of it is true we have no way of
illustrating we have no idea what
electricity is we have no idea what an
what an atom looks like so they
Illustrated and when you call Bluff they
say oh by the way that's what uh that's
philosophy okay but yeah here you have
the the atom okay that good old uh
Rutherford and uh B invented and that's
the one we use today you know you have
the electron be jumping from energy
level to energy level or orbital to
orbital and it's somewhere around it
doesn't have to be a planetary sense in
the sense that it has a fixed or orbit
it just goes back and forth it's
somewhere around the proton that's the
only change they made to uh the
Rutherford bore atom okay but
essentially it's uh electron bead
negative right which is somewhere next
to the
proton uh Center positive proton Center
and so the question is why doesn't that
bead the blue bead the electron bead why
doesn't it spontaneously Drift Away
or why doesn't it spontaneously fall
into the positive nucleus because if
it's negative you would think it's
attracted by the proton right and so
they never explain that uh they they
they don't know what keeps the electron
faithful to the nucleus and that's the
whole issue they've never answered the
question which was how they started this
issue they they started talking about
the atom uh you at the beginning of the
century uh as a planetary atom it came
you know some Studies by Bora originally
and then by Resort primarily those two
and they eventually concluded that it's
this planetary atom and we've never
gotten away from that we we we always
represent the atom as the uh orbit as
the planetary atom okay and then
obviously then that's when they deny it
okay um so here we have uh the Wikipedia
and this is what Wikipedia tells us
about spin spin should not be
conceptualized as involving the rotation
of a particle's internal Mass meaning
you know a top top spins that's not what
they're saying as ordinary use of the
word may suggest spin is a quantized
property of
waves oh man the waves are spinning and
what are waves well there's there a
bunch of vectors that's what a wave is
you look at the uh especially the
electromagnetic wave all those arrows
those engine arrows that they illustrate
those are vectors what's a vector is it
an arrow like an engine Arrow no it's uh
magnitude and Direction okay so
especially magnitude okay the very
earliest models for electron spin
imagined a rotating charged Mass but
this model fails when examined in detail
the required space distribution does not
match limits on the electron radius the
required rotation speed exceeds the
speed of light okay that's why they
figured out that spin is not spin okay
like a Top Spin because it would violate
some cherished laws of of mathematical
physics the classical analog for Quantum
spin is a circulation of energy so now
we have this thingy called Energy which
is a mathematical concept you know uh
it's just a number followed by a unit
that's what energy is you know you can
have like you know I used to work with
electron bolts uh the big accelerators
they work with Giga and maybe even Terra
electron bolts okay so they're talking
about a concept a mathematical concept
that's what they say the circulation of
energy how can a mathematical concept
circulate and yeah they use these
euphemisms and that's why people don't
understand a lot of this stuff because
it's not like kindergarten stuff where
you get a block and you say the block
moved from here to there they can't do
that with quantum um what they do is
they say they talk about math they say
oh we have this uh number plus a unit
and it
circulates or momentum density in a
particle wave field a particle wave
field particle is not a particle wave is
not a is a concept and field is a
concept so so far we have nothing in
front of us we have a mathematical
concept spin is essentially a wave
property yeah meaning it's a
mathematical property spin uh belongs to
physics whereas wave belongs to uh math
and never the twain shall meet as the
name suggests spin was originally
conceived as the rotation of a particle
around some axis right like the top
historically orbital angular momentum
related to particle orbits while the
name um based on mechanical models have
survived the physical explanation has
not in other words uh they kept the word
spin but it ain't spin quantization fun
Al Alters the character of both Spin and
orbital angular momentum since
elementary particles are point-like
right they're Point like meaning they're
made of a single piece that's what
they're trying to say there okay Point
like means it's not made of any particle
it's an elementary or fundamental
particle meaning it doesn't have Parts
self rotation is not well defined for
them now it's not that it's not well
defined it's not defined at all you
cannot talk about uh rotation
or spin or anything uh of something that
is made conceptually made of a single
piece okay not even God can rotate that
which is made of a single piece because
you would have to have at least two
points within that object right uh for
example a point on the outside a point
on the inside right and you can say okay
this point rotates or spins you know
with respect to this one you don't
because it's a single particle there is
no second point to it okay and this is
the problem with with using a
fundamental particle in talking about
spin there's a contradiction there okay
they can't they say well we cannot
exactly tell you no it's not that
exactly you can't it's impossible it's
irrational to try to say that a
fundamental particle spins period okay
so don't talk about spin which is a
physical property and you apply it to uh
this thingy which is not even a particle
which is a concept okay an abstract
mathematical concept it's a number
that's all they see okay they talk about
the mass the charge right 1.6 times 10us
19 kums that's what a an electron is for
a mathematician it's a number followed
by a unit okay it's just a relation with
respect to other uh constants or or
uh things that they've measured and
establish there you know okay so here we
have another fellow his name is James
Lincoln and he's from UCLA and he's
going to show you what spin is he says
spinning spin but then he illustrates it
is spin there you see he moving his
hands
okay so they say that spin is not spin
and they all illustrate spin as sinin
there you see them what is it doing
spinning right and uh he's saying and
there he shows it he's he's twirling it
right okay that's how he's saying that
the
electrons orbit the nucleus but you can
see how he's going to spin them okay so
this is the issue the issue is that all
these people have a contradiction and
that's because they cannot picture
anything in the quantum World they say
electron is a particle it's a Elementary
fundamental particle meaning it's not
made of a sing not made of anything
meaning it's made of a single piece
right that's what they mean and then
they talk about spin about rotation uh
uh around an axis you know it's a
mathematical concept you can't do that
with a particle that is made of a single
piece it's got nothing to rotate around
there is no you know you can't divide it
and say well I'm going to put an axis
and I'm going to put a point on the
outside of it and say that the point
rotates with respect to the axis not for
a single not for a particle that's made
of a single piece because you're in
effect saying it's made of at least two
pieces a center piece and an edge and
your violating your hypothesis your
hypothesis was that it was made of a
single piece remember and now you're
saying no it's made of two pieces one on
the outside one on the inside that's one
rotates around the inside you can't do
that because you get a contradiction
okay and these people don't understand
these things because what they never do
physics they what they're thinking about
is math they're thinking about equations
they're thinking about numbers and units
they're not thinking about physics
they're not picturing they're not
visualizing what they're saying
okay so here we have let's go with
electron spin the way the mathematicians
do it okay here it is here you have an
electron and um it's supposedly made out
of single pce I colorcoded it just so
that you could see spinning of a
particle made of a single piece you got
to think of this thing as made of a
single piece even though I color code it
is so that you can see the spin okay so
that's our starting point okay here we
have um it rolled around the proton okay
that's your hydrogen atom there okay so
we have the uh little ball on the
outside it's spinning right and it's
also rotating or orbiting the proton
which is also I guess spinning right
around an axis okay so that's the
situation and uh that's their atom okay
that's what they imagine this planetary
atom okay so keep that in mind this is
uh This Is How They picture these
things and so the question is okay let's
concede because see this linken guy says
he can explain magnetism right with this
electron spin he says oh we discovered
that every time that there's attraction
it's because the electrons on each of
the two magnets that are attracting each
other are
spinning okay let's concede okay so they
spin Okay so the electrons are spinning
tell me how the spinning of the
electrons in each magnet caus attraction
from a
distance okay and here here I try to
illustrate it for you
okay yeah you have the electrons going
around their
protons and we illustrate this as
hydrogen atoms obviously right uh
because we're trying to simplify we're
trying to get the mechanism only Okay so
so they're spinning and they're orbiting
their respective protons on two magnets
why or how by what mechanism does one
magnet attract the other now that we
have you know your electron spins okay
just tell me that every time that a
magnet attracts another you
notice that the electrons are spinning
and they're orbiting their atoms fine
and if they're all aligned no problem
tell me how this produces attraction
from a
distance okay and this is the problem
the problem is that they tell you they
give you a description but not an
explanation they cannot tell you how the
electrons do this from a distance you
know here we have two magnets right
little guys there the two dark ones okay
and so the question is you know here the
the electrons are
spinning for each one of the magnets
okay great no problem I'll concede okay
and so the question is you know why is
this already pulling on me from a
distance I mean the electron stretches
across that
divide so this is the problem the
problem is they cannot explain the
mechanism and they say that's philosophy
that's uh we don't do that and if you
don't do that why did you even try why
did you try to convince me that uh with
electron spin you can explain attraction
between two magnets you can't
you can't because you can't do it with
discrete particles which ain't particles
in in quantum physics they're just
values they call them particles but
they're values that's all they are
they're numbers they're numbers followed
by units they're talking about energy
and charge and Fields and mass and
nonsense that has nothing to do with
physics in physics you got to have the
object if you're going to talk about
balls okay tell me how a ball attracts
another ball from a
distance and the answer is you can't
you need to have some connection there
physical connection and you say Bill why
do you say that there's a connection I
can't see you touch anything in between
I can't see you touch the mediator and
the answer is very simple answer is that
if if you don't put a mediator in there
you're doing so-called physics with
black magic with um what is it
witchcraft that's what you're saying
you're saying that you're going and it
happens it does it does happen no matter
what you're doing it with black magic
and so this is the problem you have to
put a mediator in there a physical
mediator that you cannot see or touch
because a mediator is not that which you
can see your touch it's that which has
shape there's something there elongated
thing uniting these atoms right and uh
we can't see or touch it
you have to arrive at a different
hypothesis a different starting point
and then you can start explaining things
because you don't need magic now you
don't need to say well this particle
discrete particle affected that discrete
particle from a distance you can't say
that not in physics you can say that in
religion but not in physics okay okay so
here we have um uh spiraling Adam
someone U sent me uh
question there or says if all atoms in
the universe are connected what happens
to those gazillions of threads in a
rotating object like a star or a planet
do they Stack Up indefinitely if so the
objects would gain mass and volume it
would be like a snowball picking up more
snow and getting bigger as it rolls down
a hill so this fell again yeah he's
thinking in in terms of see and touch
that's the whole issue they say well you
know if this wraps around it means it's
touching right the thread and just
rolling it around okay and so um this is
this is the first problem here okay here
let me show you the definition of the
word object destroys all religions I say
that okay okay that's the first issue
and uh the second issue an object is not
that which you can see or
touch okay so whenever you use the
notion of see and touch that's you know
that's when you're going to run into
trouble you got to get rid of touch
don't bring see and touch into physics
okay because it's not about see and
touch an object is that which has
shape all objects have shape in the
universe all objects all atoms have
shape what not all things in the
universe uh are not they cannot all be
seen and that cannot all be touched you
can't see the air it's made out of atoms
you can't see it imagine the ropes that
connect you know two atoms which is
gazillions of time thinner than you know
the diameter of a of an atom and so yeah
you got to put it in that context you
can't see or touch you cannot bring the
see touch criteria and try to debunk you
know the uh rope
model um besides we don't care about
debunking there is no debunking in h
science really in science you
criticize and you explain and it's the
expl part that forms the part of science
CR criticism you can criticize if you
have a a good argument you can try to
destroy a theory and say that's not
correct that's in violation of Mother
Nature right but hopefully you can put
something in in exchange because if you
do not explain if you do not propose
something in exchange you're not a
scientist a Critic is not a scientist a
skeptic is not a scientist the scientist
is the guy who explains okay so let's
get that right we don't debunk okay what
we do is we criticize but propose
something in exchange to replace it to
say I'll tell you why yours is
irrational okay it's not that it's wrong
it's irrational and especially in the
case of mathematical physics if you're
going to be moving Concepts around you
know like mass and charge and Fields
well then you know we need to take you
in with the men with white jackets we do
not move Concepts in physics physics you
have to have objects and you have to
have a replacement for what the other
guy proposed you know you're not the
critic who's in the uh in the crowd
watching the fight you're the boxer
who's inside the fight you know you're
the guy in there that's the
scientist uh shape is the universal
property of object there is no object
you can imagine that doesn't have shape
Concepts don't have shape okay not a
single concept has shape okay but if you
know of any concept that has shape man
let me
know okay so here we have uh a
simulation try to show you how an adom
looks like under the Rope model okay and
uh this was made by my good friend Dan
Ferguson right uh took the trouble to
draw that atom there in the center and
I've used that quite a bit so I thank
him tremendously for his job right for
his work anyways uh here we have the
atom that's more or less what we think
the atom hydrogen atom lookss like okay
we have a star in the center that's the
proton and it's surrounded by this
membrane which is weaved by countless
threads not ropes threads okay and so we
have the threads making the star and the
threads making the membrane that uh
encapsulates the star and then what
comes towards that are ropes not threads
but ropes twine threads okay so we have
ropes coming towards the edge of the
atom
they uh Fork out one goes to the center
and become the blue ones in this case
right goes to the center and becomes
part of the proton and the uh red ones
they weave around and they form the
membrane that encapsulates the proton
star there's no positive there's no
negative we don't know what that is in
physics Mother Nature has no clue when
they talk about positive and negative
okay okay so that's our atom okay that's
the one we propose okay we're saying
that it's not the planetary atom it's
this atom that you see there okay and
here we have
um
uh okay I don't
have it's going to show you Quantum
Jumping I just want to show you that
that same atom expands and contracts
okay and so uh keep this in mind for
this notion of spin okay so it's going
to expand and contract is the electron
spinning electron shell is it spinning
around the proton the proton star that's
the question okay does do electrons spin
and we're not talking about a little
bead that's on the outside you know
elementary particle that is moving
around uh spinning we're not talking
about that we're saying the electron is
a membrane and whenever they talk about
the bead what they're really pointing to
is a location
on the membrane okay so that's what
they've confused for the electron bead
okay but we have this does the whole
thing rotate does it does the
electron um the whole electron membrane
spin around you know the center axis and
my guess it's it doesn't Okay and again
I'm making the assumption that it
doesn't you have to think of it more or
less like this okay uh what it's doing
is is you have all these threads right
the what we call the the uh magnetic
thread arbitrarily using the word
magnetic just to be uh consistent with
the past you know so that we don't
change the wording as we try to keep as
much with the wording as possible so we
use the electron thread uh to make the
proton star and we use the magnetic
thread to make the uh encapsulating
membrane balloon right but this balloon
is not a smooth balloon it's made out of
threads the threads are not uh you know
stretched out in the sense that um
they're uh you know like uh
straight uh or smooth uh they're
congregated you know they're bent a
little bit all around okay and what you
have is this uh this thread which is
torquing all around the uh electron
shell so all these threads are wound
around the electron shell and they're um
corrugated to some degree you know
they're uh you know they're not in a
straight line and they're twirling in
situ okay so when they they measure or
or they detect the electron at a given
point the electron shell at a given
point they say oh the electron is
spinning no what it's not spinning what
it's doing is moving
around uh like more or less I'll do it
with a rope it's not exactly this but
it's doing this you know in situ just
moving around in situ okay that's what
it's doing and so there is it's not that
the shell rotates but that the electron
thread is going all around the magnetic
thread sorry uh is going all around and
it's hting in situ okay and this gives a
sense that there is motion of not only
locally of the electron bead all right
quantum mechanics but also of the whole
shell gives an idea that the whole thing
is maybe spinning or rotating and I
don't think that's the case I think that
the reason there is such speed in the
spinning of the electron is because it's
going nowhere it's it's doing it in situ
just moving around you know at Great
speeds uh perhaps at the speed of light
you know and so they say oh oh it's
spinning and but we don't know what spin
is and it's a wave property yeah it is a
wave property because we're talking
about a little thread that has a wavess
to it and it's spinning in situ and
that's why it's so fast it goes you know
it goes all around and also in situ at a
great speed because that's how fast it's
moving okay and this is probably the
best way to picture it so um okay so
that's my take on that uh I can say uh
that you know here here's maybe a couple
more that you can ponder so that you can
try to visualize this here it is okay
here's uh you can imagine the ropes uh
converging upon this ball
and the uh locations that you see there
they're not moving you know the the the
thread that piece of thread is not
moving really what it's doing is turning
in situ it probably moves a little bit
anyways forward or backward but
primarily it's spinning in situ and
that's what gives them the idea that
there's an electron spinning uh locally
and that it's made out of a you know a
single piece it's
infinitesimally small right because
that's what they're really what's in
front of them but which they can't see
this is something you have to imagine
you have to visualize we'll never be
able to see this stuff it's just for
food for thought is for you to
comprehend it understand it and say well
you know maybe that's the way it is out
there in this Secret World of Mother
Nature's uh Adam and that's the best we
can say for
spin okay with that we'll see you next
week and uh I hope you're stay healthy
and